[ __ ] Rona I get Corona at the end of
the day I'm not gonna let it stop me
from party hey y'all check me out I got
my Corona filter going on a shout-out to
the cinematographer my man got a shot of
rona beers in there
this bastard know exactly what he was
doing he crossed them to the you know
shout out to you you knew what the hell
you was a shout out to the people
ordering piranhas during an epidemic I'm
doing this bad we need a refund
there's Marth ain't that serious Assyria
it's more serious things out there like
hunger and poverty we need to address
that
amen we know your Hurricane Katrina out
there but you know I'm saying millions
of people's died from hunger and poverty
that's just more serious I mean we need
to address that
yo I know your hearts hanging out your
chest right cuz you got two gunshot
wounds but sure one person there's more
people dying out there of other things
hey man listen listen I know eggs is a
problem like your condoms cause hunger
and poverty is a real problem you're
saying listen I know gang lives but like
it's not I think we got it you could put
play we got it listen ladies I know it's
a problem but like yo hunger and poverty
zuv rich problem Soleil if you get it on
the way home
listen if you get wine steal you get
wine see you know I mean there's hunger
there's pop you in there Lord is trying
to roll with the boy we're just living
for the moment we're just going for
we're just gonna do what happens when it
happens when stuff closes we're gonna do
when it closes but besides that we're
just try to have the best trip
we can we're just trying to make with
what we have right now this guy was
speaking less English with every word
that came out of his mouth we're just
living for the moment you know where I'm
from out there in the deep south like I
just want a mustache cuz I'm a real man
we're just lived for the moment and the
moment I need a mustache like somebody
get my GM truck and I need to ride on
out all right then it's been a great
yeah all right go Gators
what is there to do here other than go
to the bars or the beach when they're
closing all of it it's really messy I
think they're blowing it way out of
proportion I think it's doing way too
much I mean it sucks but we're gonna
make the best of you we're enjoying
ourselves
it's and I'm from the water so this
really sucks
however we're gonna enjoy ourselves we
have a date parties howdy it's my
birthday stamp Angie's name you know why
she said I'm from New Orleans it really
sucks because New Orleans is getting hit
really hard really getting hit super
hard why is that because it's a party
city listen the reason why is unknown
most likely because people are being
reckless we're gonna make the best of
this what say you mean there's an
epidemic what do you do is a pandemic
what are you talking about what are you
talking about you imagine if there's a
hurricane hitting New Orleans there
she's like yes unfortunate what's
happening but you know we're gonna make
the best of this you know it's
unfortunate what is happening with the
hurricane that's a difference like you
have a hurricane you could see it you
see the damage you see the threat coming
this is airborne and also very invisible
hmm you can't see it you can't see
what's going on you can't see the threat
coming mmm but the hurricane whoa
you see the clouds coming you see the
rain falling down you know I mean mm-hmm
that thing that's what it is that's what
the big problem is they don't see it
they don't see it people need to seeping
yeah they believe in God but whatever
Italy death search by 627 in a day
mm-hmm
yes it was two days before was 455 yeah
627 people died in one day from this
that's that's a lot of people and the
crazy thing is they're treating it yeah
they're trying to fight it at all I'd
like to understand being no harm they're
so overtaxed with people and the crazy
thing about this is it doesn't just
because because they have to take up all
this space after quarantine people to
stop it from spreading it takes up so
much of the hospital's resources people
come in with other problems can carry
you know and so they end up dying from
other unreal stuff so the death rice is
actually way higher yeah that is just
from coronavirus but this like if
someone from a car accident comes in
it's a hard-knock life the irony is that
she's obese and she's probably at higher
likelihood of having issues with this
disease there's this idea that's still
propagating this is just affecting
people over 80 know the mortality rate
is really high for people over 80 but
there's people from the ages of 20 to 45
I believe that that are being
hospitalized I think it was like 38
between twenty and thirty eight percent
of all hospitalizations are people
between the ages of 20 and 48 that is an
insanely high number when you were
hospitalized you're stuck to a machine
you may have permanent lung damage for
the rest of your life this is not a joke
I'm not fear-mongering the flu is worse
though it's not by every metric possible
the flu is not worse this is more
contagious more deadly it spreads easier
it has no symptoms it is nothing like
the flu stop so what it orally feels
like to have a girl use four teeth
during the boat this was so unpleasant
to listen to I felt pain in my okay
preach I'll let you take it away
you mean like the virus what is it
arrogance is immaturity is it also trunk
that's pushing the filling that thing is
all right and everything is under
control
Wow here's the said that for over a week
now he's been pretty much on top of it
since then but yeah but he started
partying from that time last time they
check everything was under control so
cool let me listen our prime minister's
been saying everything's not under
control and
people still out partying here in Canada
true so I can't put it on leadership a
lot of misinformation
unfortunately so a lot of people have
the wrong idea they think it's not that
big of a deal they don't realize it's
very deadly judging by how fast it's
spreading I think there's like 13,000
cases right now in America it's gonna
far exceed what's happening in Italy
Italy another one at 600 deaths a day
and it's climbing it is a very serious
thing and I think a lot of the
misinformation that came out early led
people to not believe it's not serious
so that's unfortunate I just think it
comes down to selfishness people feel
like because they're not gonna be
affected by it directly they feel like
they don't have to make any changes this
is everyone else's problem and that's a
very selfish way to look at it me
personally is not a problem for me
however because of this epidemic not
only am i losing a lot of money I think
I'm gonna be down forty forty thousand
dollars this year do the last gigs just
like the economic stuff aside I
understand that I have a social
responsibility but yeah the money's lost
but I'll take that I'll take us not
doing any outdoor events me losing I
mean I'll take that if it means that we
get to save a lot of these lives that's
what it comes down to I don't want my
neighbors the people around me dying
because I took the liberty to go outside
when we could have prevented it and it
really does work social distancing is
effective look at Hong Kong 7 million
people tightly packed in small spaces
only 200 cases 200 cases in 17 days do
you understand how impressive that is
and over grayface know they're tightly
packed look at New York Newark has 3,600
cases and they're at 8 million do you
understand the difference because Hong
Kong jumped right on it they took it
very seriously they are stopping the
spread of this virus we can save lives
and listen if you're not gonna do it for
the lives that people around you dude
for economic reasons you want to be able
to go back to work you want to be a life
to go back to normal the bed
we can do that is by stopping this virus
so if you're not gonna do it to save
other people do it for selfish reasons
whatever you need to do I don't care but
get off these streets no no this is
gonna wipe out a huge chunk of their
population already yes it's like it's
400 people yesterday 6 more than 600
today and I can't even imagine tomorrow
and it's really crazy - how you look at
the disaster movies mmm and the reason
why it's really bad is because how bad
that is that the disaster is but it
realized in real life it's not because
of the disaster it's the human response
human response that makes it like people
don't care yeah you know in like bird
box they they have to if you go outside
and you look anywhere you don't know
what's gonna happen you're gonna see
something it's gonna turn you crazy and
then there's some people it turns them
crazy some different no here's not that
hmm we have something invisible out
there yeah
stay home stay I'm not serious the
reality is even simpler than the movie
that's crazy
yeah so make an effort be smart I know a
lot of you are making that effort please
you know this is one of those times
where the minority can really ruin it
for the majority so please make that
effort if you know people who are not
taking the time please remind them the
importance we need everyone to pitch in
because if they don't pitch in you have
to stay and longer this makes everyone
else suffer that's why I'm telling
people have a social responsibility your
actions affect others try to be
considerate because if I don't come out
of the house the economy doesn't start
and if you don't get back in the house
the economy can't start I don't want my
dollar to tank I don't want all their
goods to be worthless I don't want to
see all these people look Airlines have
dropped everybody from their workforce
people I know are panicking wolfing lost
jobs I feel for them so please make the
smart move okay
[Music]